[Aplausos]
y ahora que una zurda de eliseo
quintanilla avala la acción individual
de manuel salazar fue sobre la marca de
tres hombres la tenía complicada el
árbitro que sala marcó falta y será la
zurda de eliseo quintanilla en tiro
libre una pelota pegadita sobre la banda
derecha se queda únicamente andrés
guardado para colocarse sobre el primer
poste de óscar el conejo pérez se viene
tiro libre el balón salió primero
otorgado en evitando que la pelota
llegase al destino de off y óscar el
conejo pérez
[Aplausos]
más
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en fin
[Música]
este fue el partido del salvador contra
méxico en el 2009 aquí en el cuscatlán y
ese fue el primer gol de los dos con los
que ganamos
vamos muchos vimos ese partido cierto
pues yo no lo vi yo lo oí así por radio
lo dijo mi papá
mi papá era el profesor roberto palma mi
papá dirigió y fundó una escuela de
fuego de las primeras escuelas de fútbol
que enseñaba profesionalmente el fútbol
a niños y adolescentes en el país la
escuela de fútbol de cocacola
mi papá le dedicó más de 40 años de su
vida a esta escuela de fútbol no solo la
fundó el día del señor sino que se
dedica a enseñar a porteros a delanteros
a futuros entrenadores etcétera
de verdad que la pasión de mi papá era
el fútbol
y cuando llegó el momento pero cuando
llegó el momento de de retirarse de ser
entrenador cuando ya tenía un poco más
de 70 años
mi papá pues su cuerpo ya no le permitía
ser la cancha pero definitivamente se
llevó esa pasión consigo
a nuestra casa
y mi papá pasó de ser un entrenador de
fútbol a ser un diseñador de teatros en
casa y el primer teatro en casa que
nosotros conocimos fue la sincronía
perfecta y disciplinada de mi papá de
poner varios radios por toda la casa en
su cuarto en mi cuarto en el baño en la
cocina en el patio donde sincronizada
perfectamente la misma estación de radio
y hoy el partido de fútbol y si no hoy
el partido de fútbol oía los comentarios
los análisis y todo lo que hubiera
alrededor de fútbol
mi papá amaba a estar informado
y ustedes entenderán que es bueno esta
es la radio que tenía mi papá con la que
salía así cuando íbamos al banco al psuv
pero donde fuera
sino para estar informados a mi papá lo
ponía y puede ser cuando lo lográbamos
convencer se lo metía debajo de la
camisa
pero hacía que todos escucharemos el
fútbol él necesitaba estar informado
creía que todos los demás también
estamos estado informados y esta era la
forma en cómo él salía
y cuando creímos que lo habíamos visto
todo alrededor de la información de este
dispositivo mágico que es súper sencillo
solo apaga enciende y sube y baja
volumen mi papá hizo un segundo
descubrimiento
grand theft estelar
más de uno de ustedes lo debió haber
visto y espero que más bien usted lo
haya usado porque yo lo hice
gracias por levantar la mano este puede
celulares un modelo tic tac te controla
y le sirvió a mi papá no sólo ya para
informarse con este dispositivo mágico
sino también le permitió a mi papá
evolucionar tecnológicamente ella mi
papá ya no sólo informaba sino que
estaba comunicar entonces mi papá
hablaba a la estación de radio para dar
su opinión o para regañar o lo que fuera
no su pasión de fútbol y sabe este
teléfono estoy hablando de 1999
la evolución de mi papá que esa fue
lenta se lo podemos ver en ese sentido
pero yo creo que ustedes no lo crean y
mis sobrinos no me creen
yo nací en el 81
y conmigo nació al disquete 3.5 que
estoy segura que muchos lo conocieron
también por favor espero que sí al menos
sé que mi hermana y mi cuñado sí gracias
y conmigo nació el disco nació la
segunda versión del desmán se acuerdan
del desmán don uno le ponía el cassette
y era la diferencia entre estar culo no
está el cole en el colegio y yo tuve la
suerte de vivir dos épocas una época
donde
la ley del hielo era y literalmente no
te hablo soy donde llenamos chismógrafo
que creo que luego fue la inspiración
para el facebook
vamos a libia los sismógrafos también
cierto a esas gracias
mi sobrino ya no conocieron noches
moradas
yo nací en una época donde las redes
sociales eran literalmente reunidos en
el pad en el recreo del colegio y
sentarnos en rueda y platicar
y puede evolucionar
y vivir ya lo que hacemos en la ley del
hielo
te dejo visto en whatsapp
perdón se lo hago a veces es que me meto
a reuniones y se me va la onda soy medio
pista das o te bloquea un facebook o lo
que a mí más me encanta es somos amigas
cuando nos aceptamos en facebook
y lo viví porque tuve muchas bendiciones
mi cuñada y mi hermana fundaron una las
primeras tiendas virtuales que hubo en
el país se halla por el 95 94 más o
menos
tuve la suerte de tener mi primera
cuenta de correo cuando tenía 15 años
tuve la suerte de tener mi primer
celular cuando tenía 20 27 años
y esa evolución tecnológica
me hace pensar ahora cuando preparaba
para la charla era decirles señores el
tema de tecnología no es un tema de
hallar no es un tema de futuro es un
tema de hoy
el hecho de que los jóvenes de ahora lo
primero que dan es que llegan a un lugar
no son los jóvenes todos y buscamos en
el wifi la wifi como que si uno tuviera
el crédito de hay oxígeno gratis usa de
wifi gratis y una web
y respira y se siente libre
hace unas semanas no vi esposo fuimos al
banco y nos dividimos para hacer
transacciones y entre el banco y
recuerdo que lo primero que vemos una
gran letra quise wifi gratis y me sentí
de verdad no sólo me sentí vieja sino
que me sentí emocionada porque dije por
dios he pasado años escondiéndome del
vigilante del banco para usar el celular
para decir está lleno
si nos ha pasado a todos y de repente
veo que hay wifi y address me pongo la
parte vigilante así como hola mi amor
está está lleno pero está bien tú cómo
estás
si se dan cuenta la tecnología
evoluciona de los años 80 desde una
tecnología aplicada a la gran empresa a
temas militares a ser un tema de nuestro
día
y convergieron con la tecnología yo veo
la tecnología así
yo veo todas estas macro tendencias
tecnológicas de big data inteligencia
artificial nanotecnología
'open data' el arma ching etcétera que
están revolucionando el internet de las
cosas la capacidad que tenemos de
conexión wifi bluetooth etcétera yo lo
veo como un árbol un árbol que se
ramifica para entrar en diversos temas
muchos ocupamos la tecnología para
nuestro día a día para hablarnos otros
lo hacemos para trabajar otros
trabajamos con la tecnología otro lo
hacemos para educarnos la tecnología es
esta ramificación y es una ramificación
que va creciendo y entre más va
creciendo más sombra nos va a ir dando
nos da frutos nos permite crear nuevas
cosas
la tecnología evolucionó de saber a
crear cosas
y cuando esta macro tendencia de
tecnología entra en nuestra vida
y les hablo de una macro tendencia que
sigue siendo tendencia porque sigue
siendo vigente como el celular
a ver quién dejó su celular hoy en casa
a ver levanten sus celulares quiero ver
si está segura que trae en sus entrañas
eso lo harán enciendan pantalla se
sienta más más más vamos eso muy bien
todo es en su celular no este tema no es
un tema de ayer gracias muy bien es un
tema de oro
la tecnología va evolucionando en la
medida que nosotros como humanos vamos
evolucionando y nuestras necesidades van
evolucionando
cuando nosotros como personas como
empresarios como estudiantes necesitamos
comunicarnos informarnos pero ya también
necesitamos conectarnos seguir siendo
parte de ello ahora para que esto
realmente funcione mi teoría después de
tantos años trabajando en materia de
desarrollo tecnológico en el sector
público privado en américa latina' de
ver los casos que he visto en mi familia
pues tengo la suerte esta casa de algún
informático también siendo yo economista
empresarial es que todo esto parte de un
tema para que ese árbol crezca muy
bonito y nos convirtamos realmente en un
hub de desarrollo país como queremos
tenemos que partir por aquí por la raíz
por la visión y esta raíz puede ser
empresarial si usted es su empresa está
aplicando tecnología por favor no lo
haga superficialmente entra en la raíz
apropia él en su modelo de negocios
genere roles digitales no le tenga miedo
a la tecnología sí y esta visión a nivel
nacional también parte por la
edificación de buenos cimientos de la
tecnología incentivos para desarrollar
empresas incentivos para desarrollar
productos y servicios compras públicas
fin enfocadas en tecnología ese
acercamiento en el mercado entre la
oferta y la demanda de tecnología
en mi experiencia nos gusta mucho la
parte de arriba de hablar de maestro
tendencias pero la raíz nos sigue
quedando como una deuda pendiente como
país a todos
a todos nosotros nos sigue pendiente y
por qué
el 56% la población en el país y tiene
menos de 30 años a los que ya tenemos
más de 30 y que siempre vamos a tener 30
metros no se nos note lo distinto
que estamos dejando para estas
generaciones
son generaciones que vienen con otra
mentalidad hace unos días tenía esta
radio mientras preparaba la charla
y valentina la hija de mi esposa la
garra y dice que es así ya se es para
hacer radio es para hacer música y nos
mató tanto del chiste verla reflexionar
sobre así claro pero lo tienes en tu
celular no porque no te vamos celular
mejor que qué es
esta población es la que va a marcar la
tendencia futuro señores este es su
cliente éste es su estudiante este va a
ser su jefe si este va a ser nuestro
líder
nosotros mi esposo y yo fundamos una
empresa hace un par de años dedicada a
la tecnología como servicios y cuando
fundamos esta empresa sabíamos que no
solo teníamos que ir al arriba de la
tendencia de tecnología
sino que también teníamos que entender
muy bien a nuestros clientes y una de
las primeras cosas que diseñamos fue una
metodología para desarrollar roles
digitales en las empresas porque porque
si mi cliente o el cliente de mi cliente
pero es un joven entonces tenemos que
desarrollar todas esas tecnologías
nuestros empleados tenían menos de 30
años y nos sentimos orgullosos de poder
generar empleo que dicho sea de paso
muchos de ellos vienen orgullosamente a
los centros de desarrollo de software
que diseñamos a nivel nacional para
poder promover el uso de tecnologías en
los jóvenes para desarrollar esas
capacidades de trabajo
y su espera cree eso
piensa en usted mismo en su propia
historia como ciudadano digital
hay ciudadanos digitales que nos
adaptamos de forma muy superficial como
lo hizo mi papá
hay ciudadanos que nos adaptamos porque
pasamos pues tenemos la suerte de haber
vivido las dos las dos aventuras y están
los ciudadanos digitales de ahora que lo
que quieren es trámites rápidos si
pueden comprar su entrada para estar acá
por internet por dios también quiero
poder hacer mi trámite con gobierno aquí
porque porque son ciudadanos
que ya no van a hacer eso
nosotros nos acostumbramos a hacer filas
es normal hacer filas y vamos a la
universidad inscribir bacterias hacer
filas íbamos al colegio inscribirnos
hacer filas nos acosa una manera sin
hacer filas
la tecnología no está dando agilidad
singles y señoras porque estas colas
impresionantes que tenemos ya no van a
ser de futuro
y a eso es lo que tenemos que apuntar
usar apropiadamente tecnología es la
forma más
inteligente en la que podemos generar
desarrollo las tecnologías per se no no
van a generar lo van a generar la forma
como nosotros lo usamos y si usted cree
que esta onda tecnología no le entra a
usted como alguna vez veces me dijeron a
mí por ser economista que ando haciendo
en esta onda tecnología
acuérdese de ley
ella es mary kate keller es una monja
sin cesc o religiosa es una monja fue la
primera mujer doctora en informática en
eeuu en los años 40s entonces pensar que
estoy reivindicando me veamos este
ejemplo es el tema de esta charla tenía
un sentido clave
el error que todo el desarrollo
tecnológico todavía como país no podemos
poner la imagen a esta dispositiva
esta dispositiva que es ojalá sea el
principio de no sólo mío sino hace mucho
y especialmente nosotros como país sea
el principio de un desarrollo de donde
podamos tener algo que es lo que quiero
dejarlas la tecnología por sí sola no va
a funcionar si no hay visión
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]